oh
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat comme chaque année à la
cour des comptes a présenté son rapport
annuel au parlement
à commencer par le sénat s'était tout à
l'heure à 14h30
cette année dans son rapport la cour des
comptes donne une priorité absolue aux
économies et estime que le gouvernement
aura du mal à atteindre son objectif de
maîtrise des dépenses publiques
objectif qui est fixé à 3% du produit
intérieur brut
la cour des comptes s'alarme également
et biens de l'état des finances
publiques des départements mais aussi
des finances locales en général
alors sans plus tarder direction
l'hémicycle pour écouter l'intervention
de didier migaud premier président de la
cour des comptes en écoute
la séance s'est ouverte le compte-rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué
il n'ya pas d'observation le procès
verbal est adoptée sous les réserves
d'usagé
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
dépôt du rapport annuel de la cour des
comptes huissier veuillez faire entrer
monsieur le premier président de la cour
des comptes
le premier président nous vous recevons
comme chaque année avec un grand plaisir
dans cet hémicycle pour la remise du
rapport de en ul de votre institution
depuis plus de deux siècles
la cour des comptes assiste le parlement
dans le contrôle de l'exécution du
budget votre contribution contribution
précieuse pour cet exercice essentiel de
notre démocratie a été consacré et
renforcé d'ailleurs récemment alors
l'article 47 de la constitution
je crois que dans cette assemblée nous
nous en félicitons tous votre présence
parmi nous aujourd'hui
fresnoy témoigne de votre souci de
rendre compte de manière continue et
permanente de vos travaux
comme vous le faites régulièrement
auprès de nos commissions dans le cadre
des rapports thématiques que vous
produisez je note d'ailleurs
l'imbrication de plus en plus étroite
entre nos réflexions en matière de
contrôle et votre action
cette imbrication se concrétise dans les
contrôles effectués par la commission
des finances bien sûr ou par la mission
d'évaluation et de contrôle de la
sécurité sociale et qui sont tout à fait
complémentaires au regard de l'action de
la cour des comptes les demandes auprès
de la cour émanant principalement de la
commission des finances mais également
de la commission des affaires sociales
nourrissent à leur tour votre programme
de travail et nous font bénéficier de
votre regard indépendant et de
l'excellence reconnue de votre expertise
ce renforcement de l'assistance que nous
apporte la cour est aussi un point
d'appui précieux pour le développement
de notre propre action de contrôle de
l'exécutif
vous le savez le sénat a souhaité
conforter ses capacités de contrôle de
l'action gouvernement gouvernementale en
créant une nouvelle commission pour le
contrôle de l'application des lois dont
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de souligner
le rôle et le travail je veux également
insisté sur tout l'intérêt de l'analyse
par notre institution des suites donner
à vos rapports en effet le constat que
vous présentez doit être l'occasion pour
les administrations de prendre les
mesures pertinentes pour améliorer leur
gestion et le service rendu à nos
concitoyens
si les observations de la cour se
doivent d'être objective ce qui vous
conduit parfois à la sévérité peut être
il vous appartient également de faire
oeuvre de pédagogie pour qu'elles se
traduisent par des améliorations
concrètes dans l'action des pouvoirs
publics
il est important que la cour et à
travers elle la représentation nationale
puis se constater lorsque c'est le cas
les suites positives et aussi les
progrès qui résultent de vos travaux
vous savez sur ce plan que le sénat a
pris l'initiative de mettre en place des
réunions dites pour suite à donner
entre les représentants de la cour les
rapporteurs de la commission des
finances et les représentants de
l'organisme public contrôlé les
exigences et parmi elles et l'exigence
d'exemplarité doit s'appliquer à tous
mais en particulier au parlement dans
l'exécution de son budget j'avais l'an
passé indiqué en recevant que je
souhaitais faire appel à l'expertisé de
la cour en vue d'améliorer notre
dispositif de contrôle interne en lien
avec notre commission spéciale chargée
du contrôle des comptes et de
l'évaluation interne
vous savez que les contes les assemblées
sont désormais audit et avec le concours
du conseil supérieur de l'ordre des
experts comptables pour aller plus loin
nos comptes 2013 seront certifiés
directement par la cour des comptes dans
la continuité des réflexions évoqué
devant le bureau du sénat et des
contacts que nous avons déjà eu monsieur
le premier président est en lien avec
bien sûr le président de l'assemblée
nationale
ainsi dans le respect du principe
d'autonomie des assemblées auquel nous
sommes très attachés
pourrons-nous mieux répondre
ensemble à l'exigence de clarté et de
sincérité des comptes qui font de la
confiance de nos concitoyens
monsieur le premier président je vous
donne maintenant la parole
monsieur le président du sénat monsieur
le président de la commission des
finances madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales de la
messieurs les présidents
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est un plaisir pour moi de présenter
le rapport public annuel de la cour des
comptes à la représentation nationale
ce rituel a des racines anciennes dans
l'histoire du parlement et de la cour il
a été instauré en 1832 il prend
aujourd'hui un sens renouvelé car les
évolutions récentes ont considérablement
rapproché la cour du parlement afin de
lui permettre de l'assister dans le
contrôle de l'action administrative de
l'exécution du budget de l'état dans
l'appréciation de la situation et les
perspectives des finances publiques dans
l'amélioration de la qualité des comptes
publics à travers ses missions de
certification et bien sûr dans
l'évaluation des politiques publiques et
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
président ce travail pour le parlement
représente ainsi un enrichissement
considérable de nos missions dans le
respect du rôle de chacun de décideurs
pour vous d'experts pour nous et de
notre liberté de programmation afin que
nous puissions en toute indépendance
assumer nos missions je me réjouis de
voir que les rapports qui vous sont
livrées par les observations et les
recommandations qu'ils contiennent
alimente les travaux de vos commissions
et vous pouvez compter
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs sur
notre concours sachant que comme il se
doit le dernier mot revient à la
représentation nationale
le rapport public annuel et vous le
savez notre publication
emblématique il illustre notre mission
d'information du citoyen qui est
inscrite dans la constitution
cette mission est également remplie tout
au long de l'année par la publication de
rapports et de référé sur des sujets
variés en complément de celui ci le
rapport public tu cette année traite 45
sujet le premier répond à la
préoccupation constante de la cour
d'éclairer sur la situation de nos
finances publiques et de contribuer à
leur redressement
la cour fait deux constats sur la
situation des finances publiques le
premier que le redressement des comptes
engagé en 2011 s'est poursuivie à
progresser en 2012 mais une partie
toujours importante du chemin reste à
faire c'est pourquoi les forts
entreprises selon lui doit être
poursuivie sans relâchement
en 2009 le déficit public avait atteint
le niveau historique de 7 5% du pip dont
seule une partie limitée était imputable
directement aux effets de la crise ce
niveau de déficit a placé la france dans
une situation très préoccupante en
raison de la forte progression de sa
dette
le respect par la france des engagements
pris devant ses partenaires européens en
2011 et en 2012 constitue un progrès
certain
il contribue à expliquer la faiblesse
des taux d'intérêt dont bénéficie pour
le moment la france
ce début de redressement d'une
crédibilité profondément dégradée
demeure toutefois fragile malgré les
mesures supplémentaires prises l'été
dernier le risque que le déficit pour
2012 se révèle un peu plus élevé que
l'objectif fixé à 4 5% du pib' ne peut
être écartée en raison de l'effet sur
les recettes de la dégradation de la
conjoncture
mais l'effort structurel de réduction du
déficit en 2012 a été très significatifs
ils devraient représenter 1,4 point de
pipe
toutefois selon toute vraisemblance la
situation relative de la france en 2012
sera resté moins bonne que la moyenne de
la zone euro
cela est particulièrement vrai par
rapport à l'allemagne qui a quasiment
retrouvé l'équilibré de ses comptes
publics
le deuxième constat de la cour est que
les mesures annoncées pour 2013
représente un effort considérable et
même sans précédent cependant l'objectif
de déficit effectifs de 3% n'a que peu
de chances d'être atteint en raison
notamment d'un niveau de croissance
vraisemblablement inférieur aux
prévisions
les prévisions de recettes du
gouvernement pour 2013 sont probablement
trop favorable en raison notamment de la
fragilité du scénario macroéconomique
retenu une hypothèse de croissance de
8 % apparaissait déjà optimiste au
moment du débat budgétaire elle est
désormais supérieure d'au moins un demi
point de pub à la plupart des prévisions
économiques les plus récentes
qu'elles soient du fmi de la commission
européenne de l' ocde ou des instituts
de conjoncture l'atteinte d'un objectif
de déficit effectif peut soulever des
difficultés importantes dans un contexte
de stagnation économique prolonger
l'effet récessif des mesures de
redressement lorsqu elles s'accumulent
et sont mises en oeuvre simultanément
dans plusieurs états à la fois ne peut
être négligé cela ne signifie pas que le
déficit effectif et son évolution est
sans importance car ils contribuent à
l'accroissement de la dette mais il doit
également y avoir place dans l'analyse
pour un raisonnement complémentaires que
privilégient d'ailleurs le nouveau
traité européen et la loi organique du
17 décembre 2012 ces textes conduisent
les états visés des objectifs de déficit
structurel c'est-à-dire de déficit
calculé indépendamment de l'effet de la
conjoncture économique pour faire face à
leurs engagements les états fixent
chaque année un effort structurel qu'ils
doivent réaliser par la hausse des
recettes et la maîtrise des dépenses
pour l'année 2013 les augmentations de
recettes et les économies sur les
dépenses programmées représente un
effort de 38 milliards d'euros soit
presque 2 points de pipe
un tel montant n'a jamais été réalisée
dans l'histoire récente de notre pays à
condition de réaliser concrètement cet
effort la france serait en mesure de
tenir ses engagements en termes de
déficits et des forces structurelles le
respect de l'objectif effectifs des 3%
selon toute vraisemblance à pleurer
quand à lui de nouvelles ces importantes
mesures d'ajustement dans ce contexte la
cour considère qu'il y a nécessité pour
les autorités responsables de l'union
européenne de préciser le poids
respectif qu'il importe de donner aux
critères du solde effectifs et de solde
structurel
elle invite les politiques à choisir
quels critères ils entendent privilégier
sachant que les deux ont un sens et une
importance en tout état de cause et
quelle que soit l'évolution de la
situation économique la cour insiste
c'est son premier message de fond
pour que l'effort structurel programmée
en 2013 soit effectivement et
intégralement réalisée or la cour
constate que la réalisation des deux
poids deux pipes des forces
structurelles n'est pas totalement
assurée en raison d'incertitudes sur le
produit des recettes ainsi que sur la
réalisation des mesures d'économies sur
les dépenses concernant les recettes
la cour estime que le gouvernement a
retenu des hypothèses d'élasticité du
produit des impôts à la croissance trop
favorable la cour avait déjà fait un
constat identique en 2012 si des
hypothèses plus prudentes été retenue
les recettes publiques pourrait être par
exemple inférieurs de près de 5
milliards d'euros aux prévisions
par ailleurs les dernières lois
financières ont introduit de très
nombreuses mesures fiscales nouvelles la
cour en a répertorié soixante dix ayant
chacune un impact sur l'exercice 2013
supérieure à 100 millions d'euros la
multiplicité de ces mesures rend
l'évaluation de leurs produits dans
semble fragile le rendement de chacune
d'entre elles étant susceptible
d'influencer celui d'autres en outre il
en résulte une complexification et une
instabilité accrue de notre système
fiscal qui peut être préjudiciable aux
entreprises et aux investisseurs
l'augmentation des dépenses de l'état
votée pour 2013 est de 1 milliard 200
millions par rapport aux dépenses
exécutées en 2012 cet objectif apparaît
moins ambitieux qu'en 2012 ou les
dépenses avaient été réduites de 2 1
milliards d'euros par rapport à
l'exécution de l'année précédente
encore le respect de cet objectif pour
2013 suppose style de réaliser
effectivement les économies nécessaires
pour contenir la croissance tendancielle
des dépenses
la cour constate en la matière qu une
part de ces économies reposent sur les
faits en 2013 des mesures prises sous la
législature précédente dans le cas de la
rgpp en particulier les réductions
d'effectifs opérées en 2012 les mesures
nouvelles identifiable dans la loi de
finances pour 2013 n'explicite que
partiellement les autres économies de
dépenses au delà des finances de l'état
les dépenses d'assurance maladie et de
retraite devrait augmenter
à un rythme un peu plus rapide qu'en
2012 si le gouvernement affiche une
croissance de l'ensemble des dépenses de
toutes les administrations publiques au
même niveau qu'en 2012 ce résultat
repose sur des hypothèses favorable pour
l'évolution des dépenses les moins
directement sous le contrôle de l'état
assurant chômage collectivités
territoriales opérateurs d'hiver ce qui
constitue un élément de fragilité de la
prévision d'ensemble
ainsi la loi de finances tablent sur une
hausse des dépenses d'indemnisation des
chômeurs limitée à 1,6 pour cent alors
que de son côté l'unédic l'estiment
aujourd'hui à 8,3 pour cent soit 2
milliards d'euros de différence et de
plus au total si la poursuite en 2013 du
freinage des dépenses publiques engagées
en 2011 ne paraît pas aujourd'hui hors
d'atteinte
cet effort appellera tout au long de
l'année une stricte vigilance et de
nouvelles et importantes économies en
cours d'exécution
le second message de la cour sur les
finances publiques que je tiens à
souligner à nouveau et la nécessité de
faire porter désormais l'intégralité de
l'effort de redressement jusqu'au retour
à l'équilibré sur la maîtrise et la
seule maîtrise des dépenses certain
ralentissement sans précédent des
dépenses publiques a eu lieu en 2011
puis en 2012 mais au cours des trois
dernières années le levier des recettes
a été utilisée massivement
il a représenté plus de 75 % de l'effort
ce choix s'écarte de la recommandation
ça n'est qu'une recommandation constante
de la cour d'une priorité claire donner
aux mesures sur les dépenses
dès lors la priorité absolue ne peut
qu'être d'amplifier les efforts déjà
engagés de maîtrise des dépenses dans
l'ensemble des administrations publiques
le gouvernement prévoit un tel
rééquilibrage au delà de 2013 qui se
traduira par un ralentissement encore
plus marqué des dépenses publiques
toutefois il n'a pas encore précisé les
mesures qui permettront de réaliser cet
effort exigeant même pour une partie de
celui programmé en 2013
or cet effort est possible les multiples
illustrations qui figure dans la suite
du rapport public annuel le montre bien
les dépenses publiques représentent 56
points de pub en 2011
un peu plus d'ailleurs en 2012 soit le
plus haut niveau jamais atteint en
france et le deuxième de l' ocde
un tel niveau n'appelle pas en soi un
jugement négatif il traduit un choix
collectif de préférence pour la dépense
publique
cependant ce choix ne trouve sa pleine
justification que si notre pays
s'assurent que les dépenses font la
preuve de leur efficacité et de leur
efficience
or les rapports de la cour comme les
évaluations disponibles trop peu
nombreuse d'ailleurs montre que tel
n'est pas partout le cas lorsque la
qualité de la dépense est mesurée par
exemple en matière d'éducation ou de
retour à l'emploi et je pourrais prendre
bien d'autres exemples
notre pays est loin d'atteindre des
résultats en adéquation avec
l'importance des dépenses qu'ils y
consacrent le rapport entend convaincre
les citoyens comme les pouvoirs publics
que faire mieux avec moins est possible
que les économies sont parfaitement
compatibles avec l'amélioration de la
qualité des services publics
c'est pourquoi la démarche de revue des
politiques publiques qu'elles
s'appellent rgpp ou maps doit viser
conjointement économies et améliorations
de la qualité à défaut le gouvernement
serait conduit pour respecter ses
engagements sur la maîtrise des dépenses
à appliquer les coups de rabot
indifférenciée sur des catégories de
dépenses
de son côté la cour met en avance des
pistes d'économies importantes
j'en prendrais trois exemples tirés du
rapport
un premier exemple est le dispositif des
buralistes
l'état consacre 2000-2004 des aides
importantes de plus de 300 millions
d'euros par an à cette profession
il s'agissait à l'origine de compenser
la baisse du chiffre d'affaires qui
était attendu en raison de
l'augmentation des prix du tabac
cette baisse ne s'est pas produite sauf
dans des cas très minoritaires
la rémunération moyenne des buralistes a
progressé fortement et les aides ont
entraîné des effets d'aubaine massif la
cour appelle à une remise en cause
rapide complète et intervention de
l'état en ne laissant subsister que
celles qui sont ciblés sur les débitants
en difficulté ou qui contribue à la
modernisation du réseau
un deuxième exemple d'économies
possibles pour un résultat équivalent
voire meilleur est celui des achats de
maintenance ou scinder
armer les recommandations de la cour
permettrait une économie de 10% de ses
dépenses soit 300 millions d'euros
le troisième exemple et le plan daide à
la presse écrite 2009 2011
une approche plus sélective des aides
importantes que l'état consacre au
secteur depuis 2009 une réduction de
leur ampleur et une plus forte
concentration des moyens sur les
objectifs fondamentaux de la politique
d' aides à la presse sont fortement
recommandés et de nombreux autres
exemples d'économies possibles figurent
dans le rapport
si l'effort est à notre portée si des
gisements importants d'économie existe
la maîtrise de la dépense publique ne
produira des effets à la hauteur des
enjeux que si la contrainte est
équitablement partagé entre tous les
acteurs de la dépense publique la pleine
participation du secteur local aux
efforts de maîtrise de la dépense trouve
sa justification dans la croissance
soutenue des dépenses publiques locales
au cours de la dernière décennie en
euros constants et hors transferts de
compétences bien sûr elles ont augmenté
entre 2002 et 2011 16 milliards d'euros
pour le bloc communal de 13 milliards
d'euros pour les départements et 2 7
milliards d'euros pour les régions
la cour considère que des marges de
manoeuvre importantes existent dans les
communes et les intercommunalités une
attention particulière doit entourer les
projets d'investissement touristique
sportif et culturel l'exemple du
complexe cap découverte ouvert en 2007 à
carmaux dans le tarn l'illustrent
reposant sur une ambition irréaliste 660
mille entrées payantes prévu 73 mille
deux cents réalisés en 2012 le site
connaît un déficit important non soutien
pour les collectivités concernées qui
pose la question de son avenir il
convient de tenir compte dans l'effort
demandé aux collectivités des situations
particulières à certaines catégories
d'entre elles ainsi le chapitre du
rapport qui examine la situation
financière des départements montre que
ceux ci sont en moyenne dans une
situation difficile en raison du faible
dynamisme de leurs recettes et de
dépenses accrues obligatoire dans le
champ social
toutefois d'un département à l'autre les
situations sont différentes ce qu'ils
appellent un renforcement de la
péréquation c'est à dire la
redistribution des ressources
trop collectivités l'état doit également
l'effort doit également concerner les
opérateurs c'est à dire les
établissements de statuts divers dont le
contrôle est assuré par l'état l'a aussi
d'importantes marges de progrès existent
le cas du centre national d'enseignement
à distance illustre celui d'un
établissement qui n'a ni anticiper ni
réussi à suivre la transformation
profonde des modes d'enseignement
qu'entraîne le développement des
formations en ligne
le cned doit rapidement adopté une
stratégie à la fois modernisatrice et
réaliste disposer de moyens humains
adaptés mieux les gérer
l'exemple de l'office national de l'eau
et des milieux aquatiques créé en 2007
révèle une accumulation de mission mal
assuré et de déficiences graves dans
l'organisation et la gestion
les efforts doivent aussi concerner les
administrations de sécurité sociale afin
de maîtriser les dépenses sociales et le
rapport fournit plusieurs illustrations
des marges de progrès existantes qu'il
s'agisse du pilotage et des outils de la
lutte contre la maladie d'alzheimer
notamment en termes de prise en charge
de certains médicaments à l'efficacité
incertaine de la prévention des
accidents du travail ou des télés
service public de santé en particulier
le dossier médical personnalisé une
meilleure gestion permettrait d'obtenir
à la fois de bien meilleurs résultats en
matière de santé et d'importantes
économies pour les régimes sociaux
enfin les impératifs de bonne gestion
doivent concerner aussi les entreprises
publiques les contrôles de ces
entreprises par la cour met en évidence
des pistes d'amélioration de leur
gestion ainsi elle met en garde le
groupe edf devant les risques entraîne
l'accumulation davantage sur le plan
salarial elle propose que le bénéfice du
tarif agent
c'est à dire la fourniture d'électricité
à très bas prix pour les agents soient
plafonnées et que ses modalités
d'évaluation soient conformes aux règles
de droit commun applicable aux avantages
en nature en matière fiscale et en
matière sociale elle recommande
également que les rémunérations des
cadres dirigeants tiennent mieux compte
de leur performance individuelle et
collective l'examen par la cour de la
réforme de l'audiovisuel extérieur de la
france montrent une évolution chaotique
et une dérive financière
alors qu'un dispositif plus cohérent
plus lisible et plus efficient étaient
attendues de la fusion de france 24
radio france internationale tv5monde et
monte carlo doualiya au contraire cette
fusion inachevé entraîné d'importants
surcoûts il importe de définir une
stratégie réaliste par rapport aux
contraintes des finances publiques et de
mettre en oeuvre des mutualisations
attendu en surmontant les blocages le
rapport prend aussi l'exemple des
dépenses de communication de la sncf qui
révèle des irrégularités
du point de vue de la commande publique
et certaines opérations dispendieuse et
des illustrations figurent dans le
rapport
vous le constatez des possibilités
d'économies concerne l'ensemble des
acteurs publics elles tiennent parfois
aux imperfections de la gestion elles
tiennent également souvent au mauvais
ciblage des interventions publiques la
cour constate très fréquemment que le
territoire retenu pour une action
publique n'est pas le plus pertinent ou
que les bénéficiaires d'une prestation
ne sont pas uniquement ceux qui en ont
le plus besoin pour arroser quelques
parterres de fleurs on irrigue tout un
jardin
certains chapitres du rapport met en
évidence le besoin d'une action
politique mieux centré sur les
territoires pertinents j'en citerai
brièvement trois exemples tirés du
rapport
l'étude du projet de lgv est reliant
paris à strasbourg a entraîné une
compétition entre les collectivités qui
ont financé le projet conduisant à des
choix d'investissement contestable par
exemple la construction de la gare tgv
lorraine en un lieu inapproprié a
conduit les autorités à envisager la
construction d'une autre gare à quelques
kilomètres seulement qui elle serait
relié qu'on réseau ferré régional
le chapitre sur les restructurations
hospitalières met en évidence trois
exemples de difficultés à regrouper des
structures hospitalières dont l'activité
est trop faible
ces projets ont pu conduire à des
dérives financières comme un perpignan
ou à des décisions incohérentes
comme dans la vallée de la tarentaise ou
encore dans les deux sèvres ou trois
hôpitaux proches de faible activité
pourrait coexister avec un quatrième
hôpital conçu à l'origine pour les
regrouper entièrement dans le cas du
mont saint michel le désengagement de
l'état ou pro finale
ni khamis trop faibles les effectifs ne
dispose pas des compétences adéquates a
entraîné de nombreuses déficiences dans
la réalisation du projet de restauration
du caractère maritime du mont des
défauts de ciblage ne sont pas que
territoriaux ils concernent souvent le
versement de prestations sociales ou de
subventions les exemples des aides à la
presse ou des débitants de tabac que
j'ai déjà évoqué l'île us c'est
également le cas du rsa activité que la
majorité des bénéficiaires potentiels ne
sollicite pas notamment faute d'une
bonne coordination entre le rsa et la
prime pour l'emploi pour améliorer la
qualité et l'efficience de la gestion il
convient également de réformer les
organisations administratives dans la
complexité limite la performance le
rapport cité deux exemples de la
distribution d'électricité qui repose
sur une multitude de concession souvent
de très petite taille et sur la
politique de délivrance aux étrangers de
visa et de titres de séjour pour mener à
bien les réformes nécessaire
rationalisation re ciblage
simplification une action déterminée et
continue est essentielle la cour et les
chambres régionales et territoriales le
constate lorsqu elle examine les
conséquences tirées de leur contrôle
elle cherche à rendre leurs travaux
aussi utile que possible sans vouloir
limiter leur rôle à celui d'un outil de
transparence au service de l'information
du citoyen juridictions financières se
veulent également initiateur un
accompagnateur de réforme elle s'efforce
d'associer à leur constat est critique
des recommandations d'ailleurs vous
l'avez souhaité en tant que législateur
formulé en des termes les plus
opérationnel possible
l'objet du tome 2 du rapport public
annuel est de rendre compte des enquêtes
de suivi de ses recommandations mené en
moyenne trois années après un rapport
public de la cour vous verrez que sur de
nombreux sujets les recommandations de
la cour ont été entièrement suivie ou
presque c'est l'objet de la première
partie de ce tome identifié par un
onglet verre ainsi la cour et les
chambres régionales et territoriales ont
constaté des progrès dans la gestion du
service de santé des armées du port
autonome de la guadeloupe et de la
commune d'hénin beaumont
plus généralement 71% des
recommandations des trois dernières
années sont totalement ou partiellement
suivies d'effet la cour
a identifié neuf sujets sur lesquels la
prise en compte de ces recommandations
étaient insuffisantes par exemple
l'encadrement des rémunérations dans le
secteur bancaire à la suite du plan de
soutien au secteur
le centre des monuments nationaux ou la
lutte contre le surendettement des
particuliers c'est pourquoi elle insiste
et elles sont identifiées par un onglet
orange enfin vous trouverez six exemples
de dérives persistantes qui conduisent
la cour alerter les citoyens les
décideurs j'ai déjà évoqué certains de
ces sujets le cned l'audiovisuel
extérieur de la france ou encore la
caisse de congés spectacle et sur chacun
de ces sujets identifiés en rouge la
cour alertera les citoyens les décideurs
publics ou si longtemps que nécessaire
enfin avant de conclure je souhaiterais
livre un dernier message invité les
pouvoirs publics à ne pas craindre de
dépasser les intérêts particuliers pour
faire prévaloir l'intérêt général c'est
à ce prix que les réformes nécessaires
peuvent être mises en place dans
certains secteurs
j'ai déjà évoqué les buralistes le
rapport fournit également l'exemple de
l'action sociale de la direction
générale de l'aviation civile dont le
budget important dépasse 2 63%
les crédits votés par le parlement
cet exemple complète d'autres constats
très critiques qu'a formulé récemment la
cour sur la gestion de cette direction
et celle des contrôleurs aériens
enfin le rapport lille deux exemples
territoriaux de situations dans
lesquelles l'intérêt général a été perdu
de vue la gestion cloisonné de deux
stations d'épuration continue dans
l'essonne celle d'evry et celle de
corbeil essonnes si que l'abattoir
public de basse terre en guadeloupe
sujet de carence répéter l'effort de
maîtrise des dépenses que notre pays
s'est engagé à réaliser suppose par son
ampleur un changement culturel important
un euro de dépense publique doit être
considérée par chacun comme une denrée
précieuse
aucun acteur ne doit se considérer par
principe dispensés du nécessaire
questionnement sur l'utilité et la
pertinence le juste ciblage l'efficience
de la dépense publique dont il a la
charge
il s'agit de faire en sorte que l'effort
soit largement répartie et porte sur les
dépenses les moins utiles c'est à cette
condition que l'effort programmé pour
être ré
lisez sans exiger de sacrifices
importants ou arbitraires cet effort est
possible c'est la conviction de la cour
il suppose la mobilisation de tous en
rendant compte de 45 sujet de contrôler
la cour va apporter toute sa
contribution à cette démarche
elle est dans son rôle conformément aux
missions qui lui sont confiées par la
constitution et par la loi lorsqu'elle
publie le résultat de ces contrôles
après contradictions formule des
recommandations on assure le suivi
signalent les progrès les insuffisances
et le cas échéant entière les suites
juridictionnelle qui sont pose enfin
contribuer à l'évaluation des politiques
publiques elle est également dans son
rôle quand elle s'exprime dans le débat
public pour rendre compte de ses travaux
mettre sur la table des propositions
tout en restant à sa place
consciente qu'elle est que le pouvoir de
décision appartient naturellement aux
représentants du suffrage universel
législatifs exécutifs
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci monsieur le premier président le
sénat vous donne acte du dépôt du
rapport annuel de la cour des comptes
la parole est à présent monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le premier président de la cour
des comptes
mes chers collègues cette séance
solennelle au cours de laquelle une
assemblée parlementaire reçoit le
rapport public revêt est bien entendu
toujours un caractère particulier et
plus encore aujourd'hui dans le contexte
économique et financier qui est le nôtre
monsieur le premier président ce rapport
public est impressionnant à bien des
titres d'abord quantitativement
puisqu'ils comportent en 2013 1800 pages
1200 pour les observations et 600 pour
les suites c'est plus du double du
rapport public de 2010 et je ne sais si
nous devons prolonger la courbe pour
arriver notamment à trois mille six
cents pages en 2016 mais ceci n'est
évidemment que l'accessoire le principal
c'est ce que vous nous avez dit monsieur
le premier président est en vous
appuyant sur deux séries de
considération les unes d'ordre global
est en nous appelant à notre sens des
responsabilités collectives et les
autres à partir des 45 sujet que vous
avez exploré et c'est bien cela me
semble-t-il mes chers collègues qu'il
faut retenir dans la démarche de la cour
dans la démarche de la cour depuis
toujours mais peut-être encore plus dans
le nouveau contexte européen auquel nous
sommes confrontés
la concomitance et la correspondance
entre les observations de nature globale
et la technicité issus des contrôles sur
le terrain et dans des organismes et
services de toute nature sur le premier
président vous avez évoqué le
redressement des comptes publics
vous avez dit et ceci sera agréable à
entendre au moins par une partie de
l'hémicycle qu'il avait été engagé en
vous avez dit qu'il avait été poursuivi
en 2012 et en 2012
sous l'impulsion de deux gouvernements
d'orientations différentes et vous nous
avez livré votre appréciation celle de
la cour des comptes sur la prévision de
croissance pour 2013 que vous considérez
manifestement comme très optimiste
de la même manière que vous avez appelé
notre attention sur les recettes
fiscales et sur la vraisemblance de
chiffres réels moins élevés que ceux qui
se trouvent dans la loi de finances
initiale pour 2013 beaucoup d'entre nous
ont fait valoir lors de l'examen de
cette loi de finances que si l'hypothèse
de croissance avait été plus réduite
moins optimiste
il aurait bien fallu arbitrer les
dépenses à un niveau moins élevé mais
naturellement il appartient au
gouvernement et il appartiendra aux
aspects il appartiendra aux assemblées
parlementaires de s'assurer selon
d'ailleurs les recommandations de la
cour des comptes de la bonne tenue des
objectifs et du sentier de convergence
qui accrédite notre sérieux aux yeux de
l'ensemble de l'europe et de notre
environnement international vous avez
mis l'accent monsieur le premier
président sur le caractère apparemment
paradoxale des nouvelles règles issues
du traité européen le tsc g et de la loi
organique qui le décline car jusque là
on raisonnait en termes de soldes
effectifs de sol de nominal et à présent
on raisonne en termes d'effort
structurel de déficit structurel
ce qui nous renvoie à des notions
économiques beaucoup plus complexe et
délicate d'appréciation c'est notamment
mes chers collègues la raison pour
laquelle le sénat lorsqu'il a examiné et
au demeurant ce qui est rare ces
temps-ci sur la base d'un assez large
consensus
le projet de loi organique sur la
gouvernance des finances publiques c'est
la raison pour laquelle le sénat a
attaché beaucoup d'importance à la mise
en place de la du nouveau collège
qu'est que sera à partir du 1er mars
prochain le haut conseil des finances
publiques
je me permets de le rappeler à
l'ensemble de nos collègues c'est bien
ce haut conseil qui sera en charge
d'effectuer les comparaisons nécessaire
de vérifier les méthodologies mise en
oeuvre et de livrer un avis public et
qui me semble-t-il
et on le verra très vite pourrait avoir
une très grande importance et pour la
crédibilité de notre pays et pour sa
gestion budgétaire
donc monsieur le premier président cette
année 2013 qui est l'année au cours de
laquelle le haut conseil des finances
publiques va effectivement se mettre en
place est une année
vous avez des limites est en quelque
sorte les principaux repères et en nous
indiquant quelles sont les zones de
danger dont nous devrons nous nous
défier et bien entendu dans une telle
période
après avoir rappelé que l'essentiel de
l'ajustement les deux tiers en 2012
s'est fait par une hausse des
prélèvements obligatoires dans une telle
période
il est clair que l'attention devra être
portée encore bien davantage sur la
maîtrise des dépenses publiques à tous
les niveaux s'agissant de l'état de la
sécurité sociale et des administrations
territoriales ainsi que vous nous l'avez
dit peut-être mais c'est une autre
question est un autre débat
certains seront ils interpellé par
l'apparenté contradiction entre tel
projet de réforme par exemple des
rythmes scolaires susceptibles de se
traduire par des dépenses publiques
supplémentaires et par ailleurs la
nécessité où on se trouve
avant même toute mesure nouvelle de
réaliser des efforts très importants et
probablement douloureux en ce qui
concerne la gestion des administrations
publiques
mais bien entendu mais ceci est vrai de
l'ensemble des secteurs mes chers
collègues sur lesquels nous exerçons
notre attention nous nous lirons dans le
rapport public annuel
comme chaque année le lot de
dysfonctionnement de pratiques
répréhensibles d'avantagés injustifiés
de dilapidation d'argent public de
gestion irresponsable
quelle que soit la nature des organismes
visés et je crois qu'il n'est pas
anormal que l'on s'interroge lorsque
l'on regarde le secteur public les
services publics sur les rémunérations
des salariés d'edf
et sur leur connexion que l'on voudrait
plus manifeste avec les performances de
l'entreprise pour ne pas parler des
avantages annexes et de la gestion et
des organismes sociaux au sein de ce
grand groupe
s'agissant des collectivités
territoriales bien entendu nous serons
tous très attentifs à vos propos avons
vetri et ceux qui figurent dans le
rapport public met notamment l'accent
sur les perspectives financières très
contrainte des départements or ici dans
cet hémicycle à de très nombreuses
reprises
ce thème a eu un grand succès n'est ce
pas mes chers collègues sur toutes les
travées de notre hémicycle
or la cour partant du déséquilibre
croissante de la structure financière
des départements constat que nous
pouvons partager et se prononce pour des
solutions plus adaptées que la création
de fonds d'urgence dont nous savons tous
qu'ils ne sont pas à la hauteur des
difficultés structurelles à résoudre or
la cour propose et c'est là je le
suppose mes chers collègues que notre
vision sera sans doute moins concordante
avec la sienne une modification de la
répartition des ressources fiscales
entre le bloc communal et le niveau
départemental ce qui veut dire que l'on
jouerait les uns contre les autres ou
que l'on imaginerait de déshabiller
pierre pour habiller paul
alors que vous le savez monsieur le
premier président si la variété des
situations financières des départements
est très grande
celle des communes et intercommunalités
et coisy menthe infinie et le président
de la région bourgogne a raison
de nous inciter à regarder aussi du côté
des régions notamment en charge de la
formation professionnelle grands enjeux
s'il en est un dans cette période de
difficultés sociales
nous attendons monsieur le premier
président avec intérêt par avance le
premier rapport public annuel de la cour
sur les finances publiques locales qui
doit paraître au second semestre 2013
mais nous ne saurions trop vous inciter
à une approche équilibrée selon les
niveaux de collectivités et en regardant
de manière réaliste les contraintes qui
s'applique aux uns et aux autres et je
le répète dans cette période de
difficultés sociales et dans cette
période où le lien social est
particulièrement important entre nos
concitoyens
monsieur le premier président je
terminerai en évoquant et les différents
contrôles auxquels vous avez procédé et
les sujets d'investigation qui sont les
vôtres rejoignent bien souvent les
préoccupations des parlementaires et
plus précisément ceux de la commission
des finances dans le cadre de notre
mission de contrôle budgétaire même si
nos appréciations divergent parfois
j'indiquerai que parmi les sujets ayant
fait l'objet d'investigations de nos
rapporteurs spéciaux figure la
délivrance des visas et des titres de
séjour
les concessions de distribution
d'électricité et le fonctionnement du
passé la monnaie de paris et la gestion
immobilière commune à l'institut de
france et à la monnaie de paris la
fondation du patrimoine et ses recettes
affectées
les établissement d'aménagement du
quartier de la de la défense bien
souvent les insertions du rapport public
mes chers collègues sont une incitation
à aller plus loin et c'est le cas en
particulier s'agissant du plan daide à
la presse des années 2009 2011 et du
régime des aides
blick à la presse nous venons de
demander sur ce sujet un travail
complémentaire une enquête de la cour au
titre de l'article 58 2 de la loi
organique sur les lois de finances et
nous avons tenu tout récemment une
réunion de travail pour en préciser le
programme et les objectifs
ceci devrait nous permettre de
confronter aux développements les plus
récents et à leurs exigences
les propositions qui devraient être
formulées par un groupe de travail que
la ministre de la culture a récemment
mis en place sans doute aussi nous
interrogeons nous sur cet élément
supplémentaire des à la presse qu'ils
seraient le fait d'une société
multinationale google qui apporterait 60
millions d'euros n'est ce pas sous un
statut assez difficile à définir et dans
le cadre de règles de répartition et qui
elle aussi présente encore me
semble-t-il un caractère flou en tout
cas monsieur le premier président la
commission aura le plaisir de vous
accueillir et de vous questionner le 27
février prochain
dans cette attente et à titre de
conclusion je rappellerai mes chers
collègues que dans la publication de la
cour
il y à une partie qu'il ne faut pas
négliger ce sont les réponses des
administrations c'est à dire les pages
colorées du rapport et bien entendu si
les textes de la cour résultant de sa
procédure collégiale et qui fait
toujours la preuve de son efficacité
mérite notre tout premier intérêt et les
réponses les observations des
administrations peuvent aussi s'avérer
de caractère très instructif
au regard de la sociologie administratif
par exemple mais aussi parfois de
manière éclairante sur les limites de la
solidarité gouvernementale
si on lit un peu entre les lignes si
l'on décrypte les nuances d'appréciation
porté par les différents départements
ministériels
feriel sur certaines politiques
publiques donc je ne saurais trop vous
conseiller mes chers collègues d'aller
jusqu'au bout de la lecture et des
tendres celle-ci jusqu'aux pages
colorées du rapport quant à mon propre
au final il concernera les relations
entre la cour des comptes et la
commission des finances
nous avions évoqué l'an dernier la
question des délais de transmission des
travaux de la cour avec un arbitrage à
trouver entre le droit de priorité du
parlement et la publicité rapide par
mise en ligne d des éléments du rapport
public
à cet égard je pense que la mise au
point d'une plateforme d'échangés
électroniques est un réel succès et de
notre côté mes chers collègues
il nous reste à être encore plus
performant en ce qui concerne les délais
de publication et de diffusion des
enquêtes remise par la cour notamment
dans le cadre de nos coopérations
selon l'article 58 paragraphe 2 de la
loi organique sur les lois de finances
mes chers collègues je vous remercie de
votre attention
merci monsieur le président la
commission des finances la parole est à
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales
ainsi l'ue
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues
rendez-vous désormais traditionnel nous
nous retrouvons aujourd'hui pour la
présentation de votre rapport annuel
votre publication emblématiques comme
vous disiez il y a un instant monsieur
le premier président et comme chaque
année ce document est conséquent et
d'une très grande intensité
j'émettrais donc un petit regret
personnel c'est le peu de temps que j'ai
pu avoir pour pouvoir aujourd'hui
débattre avec vous de ce rapport fort
intéressant comme à chacune de ces
publication de ce rapport annuel attire
l'attention sur plusieurs cas de
mauvaise gestion et provoque
l'inquiétude de celles et ceux qui sont
visés par vos observations
fort heureusement ces observations
s'accompagne de vos recommandations en
vue d'une utilisation plus efficace des
fonds publics au service des usagers et
je sais qu'il s'agit là de votre
principale préoccupation
d'ailleurs la seconde partie de ce
rapport est consacrée au suivi de vos
recommandations antérieures et témoigne
des évolutions de nos administrations
collectivités et organismes dont le
fonctionnement se trouve mis en cause
elle témoigne aussi des difficultés de
certains d'entre eux à mettre en oeuvre
ces recommandations
en tout état de cause ce rapport annuel
constitue à plusieurs titres
une source d'information de premier
ordre pour les membres de la
représentation nationale
à cet égard je ne reprendrais pour ma
part que quelques-uns des thèmes fort
variés contenues dans cette publication
vous l'aurez bien sûr compris ceux
concernant la commission des affaires
sociales ce document a d'abord le mérite
de nous éclairer quelques semaines après
la discussion du plf mais aussi du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale sur les hypothèses
macroéconomiques utilisés par le
gouvernement pour définir les contours
des textes financier de l'automne
à cet égard nous enregistrons votre
constat selon lequel les prévisions de
croissance de la masse salariale qui
sous-tendait les projections du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour être
se révéler trop optimistes optimiste et
entraîné en 2013 un recouvrement de
cotisations sociales et de csg inférieur
aux attentes
je compléterai cette observation en
matière de recettes en baisse par le
nombre de plans sociaux et la timidité
des chefs d'entreprise en matière
d'embauché qui en sont finalement aussi
les causes tout comme la faiblesse
endémique des salaires nous serons bien
entendu attentifs à l'évolution de cette
situation et aux mesures qui seront
nécessaires le cas échéant pour garantir
le financement de notre protection
sociale dans l'intérêt des assurés
sociaux
au-delà de ces grands équilibres le
rapport annuel rejoint par le biais de
nombreuses insertion consacrés au
domaine de la santé et de la cohésion
sociale
certaines des préoccupations ponctuelle
des membres de la commission des
affaires sociales je me félicite par
exemple que la course se soit intéressé
à l'avenir de la branche accidents du
travail maladies professionnelles la
branche at mp dossiers auxquels nos
collègues jean pierre godefroy et
catherine de roche
on cause consacré un travail approfondi
dans le cadre de la mission d'évaluation
et de contrôle de la sécurité sociale et
que vous traitez cette année au titre
des réformes inachevées la
complémentarité de ces travaux qui
concernent les modalités d'apurement de
la dette de la branche at mp et la
nécessité de renforcer la politique de
prévention ouvre des perspectives
intéressantes pour les réformes à
entreprendre au niveau de la gestion de
cette branche
je pense aussi à la question des
restructurations hospitalières sujet ô
combien sensible pour les élus locaux
que nous sommes sur lesquelles les
chambres régionales des comptes se sont
penchés cette année et que notre
commission suit avec attention depuis
plusieurs décès plus d'une décennie
pardon à cet égard si la carte
hospitalière mérite sans doute d'être
révisé je tiens à réaffirmer notre
attachement à une offre de soins
respectueuse des spécificités
territoriales et proches des populations
de mon point de vue que je sais
largement partagé dans cette enceinte
une approche purement con
abl d'un tel projet se traduirait
inévitablement par une remise en cause
des conditions d'accès aux soins pour un
grand nombre de nos concitoyennes et
concitoyens et une dégradation
inacceptable de la sécurité sanitaire
dans notre pays
or au travers du pacte pour l'hôpital de
marisol touraine ministre des affaires
sociales et de la santé et du discours
de jean marc ayrault premier ministre
vendredi dernier à grenoble
le gouvernement a rappelé son
attachement à un égal accès aux soins de
l'ensemble de la population
l'actualité souligne trop souvent qu'en
ce domaine le mot le moindre laisser
aller à moindre concession peuvent se
traduire par des conséquences
dramatiques
ici encore je me référer aux travaux de
l'amex la mission d'évaluation et de
contrôle de la sécurité sociale puisque
dans leur rapport adopté par notre
commission à l'unanimité
nos collègues jacky le menn et alain
milon préconisait d'ajuster le mode de
financement actuel afin de garantir les
activités essentielles à l'offre de
soins sur un territoire en tenant compte
des contraintes géographiques en matière
de politiques territoriales dans la
tente de la publication du premier
rapport annuel consacré aux finances
locales
ce rapport aborde également un thème
cher aux membres de notre assemblée
je veux parler monsieur le premier
président des perspectives financières
des départements en soulignant que
ceux-ci doivent faire face à une
progression soutenue des dépenses de
solidarité qui leur incombent vous en
avait parlé il ya un instant le rsa
l'apa et la pch à l'aide de recettes
fiscales peu dynamique
la cour nous rappelle si besoin était
l'urgente nécessité de repenser des
relations qu'entretiennent nos
collectivités avec leurs principaux
partenaires en matière de politique
sociale et en particulier avec l'état au
delà de l' équilibre budgétaire des
départements il en va tout simplement de
la pérennité de dispositifs dont
l'utilité et l'efficacité n'est plus à
démontrer nous pouvons diverger sur les
solutions mais sur le constat l'effet
ciseau recettes fiscales dépenses
sociales est une vraie difficulté pour
les départements
un mot enfin sur le jugement sévère
porté par le rapport sur les conditions
de mise en oeuvre du parcours de soins
coordonnés nous ne pouvons à ce sujet
qu'adhérer à vos observations et
regretté les incohérences
qu'il s'agisse de la complexité des
tarifs de l'augmentation injustifiée du
reste à charge ou les faibles résultats
obtenus en termes d'amélioration des
soins d'une réforme dont l'objectif
était pourtant compris par les assurés
et il est temps de remettre le patient
au coeur du dispositif est d'assurer aux
médecins traitants la place de pivot qui
devrait être la leur monsieur le premier
président mes chers collègues
à l'issue de ces quelques remarques je
tiens néanmoins à rappeler que le
rapport annuel n'épuise pas loin s'en
faut
l'ensemble des relations
qu'entretiennent la cour et la
commission que je préside le président
jean pierre bel a d'ailleurs rappelé
dans son propos introductif la cour et
notre assemblée sont en pardon de
multiples occasions de travail partagé
en effet dans le cadre de la mission
d'assistance confié à la cour par la loi
organique relative aux lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale
différents rendez-vous spécifiquement
consacrée aux finances sociales rythme
depuis 2005 le calendrier de notre
commission
en juin la présentation du rapport de la
cour sur la certification des comptes de
la sécurité sociale nous permet de
bénéficier de données audités reflétant
fidèlement le résultat le patrimoine et
la situation financière du régime
général et des branches qui la composent
compte tenu de la nécessité de redresser
l'état de nos finances sociales
cet outil se révèle chaque année
particulièrement utile pour constater la
sincérité des comptes et améliorer les
modalités de gestion des différents
organismes
il conviendrait néanmoins qu'ils ne
fassent pas seulement des
recommandations sont les dépenses mais
aussi sur les recettes en septembre
votre audition monsieur le premier
président à l'occasion de la publication
du rapport sur l'application des lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale sonne
le coup d'envoi de notre période
budgétaire c'est-à-dire du projet de loi
de financement de la sécu
cette année encore les analyses de la
cour concept consacrés aux dispositifs
fiscaux et sociaux propres aux retraités
ou à la fonction redistributive
les prestations familiales ont permis à
chacune et chacun d'entre nous de se
forger un avis sur des choix de société
aux conséquences importantes pour la vie
quotidienne de nos concitoyennes et
concitoyens même si plusieurs solutions
peuvent s'exprimer au sein des
différentes familles politiques
enfin les relations que nous entretenons
passe par les enquêtes que nous vous
demandons de réaliser au titre de
l'article 130 2-2 3-1 du code des
juridictions financières dans ce domaine
je pense que la commission s'est efforcé
de tenir compte des modalités de
publication des délais de réalisation
suggérée par la cour nous avons ainsi
défini l'an dernier un calendrier de
travail pluriannuel permettant aux
chambres régionales des comptes de
disposer du temps nécessaire pour
analyser efficacement les aides à
l'apprentissage et la question des
maternités deux enquêtes qui nous seront
livrés dans le courant de l'année 2014
dans le même esprit nous avons pris soin
de réduire les délais ses parents la
remise des enquêtes par la cour de leur
publication par la commission par
exemple de l' enquête relative à la
politique vaccinale de la france
présenté en décembre par le président de
la 6ème chambre devrait être ainsi rendu
public d'ici la fin de la semaine à
l'issue d'un intense travail d'auditions
complémentaires réalisés par notre
collègue et rapporteur georges labazée
travail présenté à la commission ce
matin même et qui a suscité je vous le
garantis mes chers collègues un très vif
débat est un gars également très riche
débat sur ce sujet si la commission est
pleinement consciente des différentes
préoccupations de la courge souhaiterait
monsieur le président qu un accueil plus
enthousiastes soient réservés aux thèmes
dont nous aimerions vous saisir comme
l'an dernier je constate en effet que
nos interlocuteurs n'ont pas souhaité
donner suite à certains d'entre eux en
dépit de leur intérêt pour les
parlementaires et pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens je pense
notamment
aux dispositifs médicaux pour 2011 et
cette année nous avions demandé un
rapport sur la tarification des ehpad
je ne pense pas que nous pourrons la
voir cette remarque que mis à part
remarque qui me permet de souligner
l'existence de marges de manoeuvre une
collaboration plus efficace
je tiens en guise de conclusion à me
félicité des bonnes relations qui nous
anime relations dans l'intensité
grandissante reflète l'importance
croissante prise par les finances
sociales au sein de nos finances
publiques
je vous remercie voilà pour la
présentation du rapport annuel de la
cour des compte à présent je vous
propose de suivre les auditions
préparatoires au projet de loi ouvrant
le mariage aux personnes de même sexe
cet après midi à les sénateurs de la
commission des lois
entendez des personnalités qualifiées
dans le domaine de la psychanalyse
audition que je vous propose de suivre
tout de suite bien mes chers les chers
collègues je vous remercie d'être venu
peu pour cette ou ces auditions cet
après midi